equilateral trapezoid isosceles
tetrahedron I have never seen a mind
like the one your daughter has you have
to see
which she becomes Catherine we all go
end up unemployed riding around in this
pilot jumping you welcome to off the
sixteen men all sit in the back of the
bus you have identification on
we just don't know way to work at NASA
quite a few women working in the space
program
you know we're putting a human on top of
a missile shooting under space and it's
never been done before
I need a mathematician it could look
beyond the numbers man that doesn't yeah
just before the Russians plant a flag
from the dam you have someone she can
handle any numbers you put in front
don't embarrass me this was an empty
last night sorry I'm not that Colonel
Jam is a tall glass of water it's coming
over yeah why would he be doing that
Mary wait a minute Oh Johnson sliced a
pattern of what you already have a
computer nest and that women handle that
sorted that women do some things at NASA
mr. Johnson and it's not because we're
Leia skirts because we wait glasses we
go from being our fathers daughters to
our husbands wives to our babies mothers
everything came out with Mama gone for
12 and a half days no but it felt like
it I don't like it too me too
it's crunch time in 14 days astronauts
will be here for training everything we
do can matter to their wives to their
children
I believe is gonna matter to the whole
damn country my gals are ready we can do
the work that's John Gillian what do you
ladies do for NASA calculate your
knowledge in handy sir
engineering and I'm proud of the devil
to be working with you
there is no protocol for women attending
there's no protocol for man circling the
Earth either sir every time we have a
chance to be the head they load a finish
line every brief time we all get there
together we don't get there at all
let me ask you if you have white mane
would you wish to be an engineer I
wouldn't have to I'd already be them
don't you know that we're able